welcome back if you're noticing all
those extra squats are not helping you
build the buns you want
it might be time to consider a lift
rocky spoke to a local plastic surgeon
to get some answers welcome to smith
plastic surgery where dr lane smith
designed his very own state-of-the-art
offices
let's just say he has an eye for
buildings and for bodies especially
when you're ready for a brazilian butt
lift it's mainly making the buttocks
larger by
transferring fat so what we do is we
take fat from problem areas
and place them into the buttocks smith's
plastic surgery has been doing this
procedure for 16 years and was actually
the very first
to bring it to the vegas market where
you know nice butts are in high demand
there's a lot of women who who work in
various industries from cocktail
waitresses to people who are in shows
they need to be curvier it is a myth to
think that you can get curvier just by
getting fat
people think that okay fat is
distributed genetically and it can be
you can be very fat and have nothing in
your in your bum and hips
or you can be thin and have a lot the
main goal
of the brazilian butt lift is not to
make a bigger bum that's certainly one
of the goals
but it's to make a curvier figure a
narrower waist
you know a little larger buttocks and
maybe a little larger hips
patients will come in and say hey i look
like spongebob and and they thought you
know if i gained some weight they'd get
curvier but you know the weight goes to
all the wrong
places if they don't already genetically
have it nicely distributed
so we can fix that and no you can't just
rely on exercise and diet to get the
curves you want
you really can't just get it by by
eating more or even
a little bit by exercising and increase
the gluteal muscles but you can't really
get curvy
unless you're kind of genetically
predisposed for that or unless we help
you
and that help goes a long way when you
take the fat from the problem areas then
your problem areas have less fat cells
forever
but i'll let the expert explain in the
future if you gain weight instead of
going to your problem area it might be
your waist or your arms
it'll go to your bum and hips so that's
kind of nice you know it kind of
goes in the right place finally you know
instead of the wrong place the curvy
figure wasn't always the most common
desire though
culture's changed okay in the 70s and
80s you know
femininity was all breasts and now it's
going back to hips
and buttocks things that distinguish a
woman from a male
and that's something that is encoded
right deep in our dna
and you know influences like kim k j low
nicki minaj cardi b
all well known for their backsides help
make the brazilian butt lift the fastest
growing procedure in plastic surgery
but it's also the most dangerous what
makes this dangerous is possible to
inject the fat instead of into where we
want it
into a vein and it can it can go through
the vein and block the harder lung make
it very serious
and the fat has a little bit higher risk
of infection too when we inject it so
these two things make it the most
dangerous plastic surgery procedure
fortunately both things are sort of very
avoidable and
you know if you do the procedure
properly and keep it in the
with the fat where it belongs which is
not into the muscle and definitely not
under the muscle that's where the big
veins are
you can you can avoid having that
problem if you
we mix the fat with antibiotics you can
drop the infection rate very low
so that's that's ways to avoid it for
the public
i would say if you're going to do this
procedure okay
make sure that the surgeon you're doing
it with is board certified
by the proper boards okay plastic
surgery
that they that they are have done
many of them they can show you lots of
pictures and that they have a good
safety record
for more information call 702-838-2455
or head to smithsurgery.com